let's multiply one point to one or one
and 21 hundredths times 43 thousandths
or 0.043 and I encourage you to pause
this video and try it on your own so
let's just think about a very similar
problem but one where essentially we
don't write the decimals let's just
think about multiplying 121 times 43
which we know how to do so let's just
think about this problem first as kind
of a simplification and then we'll think
about how to get from this product to
this product so we can start with so
we're going to say 3 times 1 is 3 3
times 2 is 6 3 times 1 is 3 3 times 121
is 363 and now we're going to go to the
tens place so this is a 40 right over
here so since we're in the tens place
let's put a zero there 40 times 1 is 40
40 times 20 is 840 times a hundred is
4,000 and we've already known how to do
this in the past and now we can just add
all of this together and we get and we
get them to a new color here 3 plus 0 is
3 6 plus 4 is 10 1 plus 3 plus 8 is 12 1
plus 4 is 5 so 121 times 43 is 5,200 and
3 now how is this useful for figuring
out this product well to go from 120 to
go from 1 point 2 1 to 121 we're
essentially multiplying by a hundred all
right we're moving the decimal two
places over to the right and to go from
zero point zero 4 3 2 43 what are we
doing we're removing the decimal so
we're multiplying by ten hundred
thousand we're multiplying by 1,000 so
to go from this product to this product
or to this product we essentially
multiply two by a hundred and we
multiplied by a thousand so then to go
back to this product to go back to this
product we have to divide
we should divide by a hundred we should
divide by 100 and then divide by a
thousand which is equivalent to dividing
by a hundred thousand but let's do that
so let's rewrite this number here so
five thousand two hundred and three
actually let me write it like this just
so it's a little bit more aligned five
thousand two hundred and three and we
could imagine a decimal point right over
here if we divide by a hundred C divided
by ten divided by a hundred and then we
want to divide by another thousand so
divided by ten divided by hundred
divided by a thousand so our decimal
point is going to go right over there
and we're done one point two one times
zero point zero four three is zero point
zero five two zero three so one way you
could think about it is just multiply
these two numbers of this as if there
were no decimals there then you could
count how many digits are to the right
of the decimal and you see that there
are one two three four five digits to
the right of the decimal and so in your
product you should have one two three
four five digits five digits to the
right of the decimal why is that the
case well when you ignore the decimals
when you just pretended that this was
121 times 43 you essentially multiply
this times a hundred thousand by a
hundred and a thousand and so to get
from the product you get without the
decimals to the one that you need with
the decimals you have to then divide by
a hundred thousand again multiply by a
hundred thousand is essentially
equivalent to moving the decimal place
five places to the right and then
dividing by a hundred thousand is
equivalent to moving the decimal five
digits to the left
so divided by ten divided by a hundred
divided by a thousand divided by 10,000
divided by a hundred thousand but either
way we are done this is what this is
what we get